(upbeat instrumental music)
- The three things that you
can do to close the wealth gap
and fight for wealth justice:
vote, donate, intersectionality.
When we vote, we are electing people
who will enact fiscal policy.
Fiscal policy is the way
that money gets allocated
to certain things in our local,
state, and federal budgets.
We should donate to
organizations like BlackFem
because they tend to be
typically underfunded
and they're doing the wealth justice work
that is going to close the wealth gap
for marginalized populations.
And finally, and I think most importantly
because this is something
that we can hold ourselves
accountable to every day,
we have to think about wealth inequality
from an intersectional lens
across race and gender.
For every dollar a single Black man owns
a Black woman only owns 42 cents.
So when we only tend to couch the idea
behind wealth inequality
in just one dimension,
race, gender, or class,
we actually are rendering
Black women's inequality
that they experience from a
wealth perspective invisible.
So the issues that show up in our society
and the inequalities that
we're struggling against
have to be met with
solutions that are aligned
with the intersectionality
of our identities, our past,
and what we ultimately want to see
to be able to create change.
(upbeat instrumental music)